did you notice that the that the time
between each talk by its each performer
got slower and slower why the suspense
got higher higher and higher mercifully
so we both know what it is to be in the
audience about this time holding our
breath wondering if our names are going
to be called yes
the nominees tonight for outstanding
performance by an actor in the leading
role are Warren Beatty and love in
heaven can wait Gary Busey and the Buddy
Holly story
Robert De Niro in The Deer Hunter
Laurence Olivier and the boys from
Brazil Jon Voight in coming home
like this I came a long ways to do this
union your dude didn't you well the
winner is will suspense here the winner
is
john-boy
I am I'm still reeling really from the
appearances just recently on the stage I
don't think there's an actor here or or
watching this proceeding tonight who
doesn't acknowledge a great debt to the
continuing legacy of Laurence Olivier
and
and his presence here tonight is put a
great perspective and just on the
proceedings for me and warm and generous
and dignified one and I'm not quite able
to recover from it I tell you the
performances this year in this category
are remarkable really I am I am a great
fan of the other members of the
nominating body nominated body and I
know that we are all extremely aware of
the extraordinary performances that we
have been selected to represent for my
own part I I have as we all do many
people to thank for a performance which
stands among this group of performances
I would like to thank everyone but I
select to thank a few who represent the
many I would like to thank Bruce during
my friend for his encouragement and his
wonderful performance and his friendship
I would like to thank
I would like to thank Gerry Hellman who
produced also Midnight Cowboy is an
extraordinary man a great producer a
tenacious fighter who keeps us all
healthy and has great taste
I would I would like to thank how Ashby
a remarkable a remarkable person who was
so helpful in getting me to myself and
encouraging my performance and finally I
would like to thank Jane whose great
dignity as a human being it's a good
thing she's not here to see this is very
moving to me and and finally I'm
carrying with me all all the men who
gave me so much of their experience to
deal with who have contributed so much
the people in chairs and the veterans
and civilians and the walkers who are so
strongly represented in what I call my
work thank you very much